today's video is brought to you by
myheritage an incredible way to build
your family tree and discover your
origins more about them in just a bit
julius caesar spartacus sula marcus
crassus all of these men have had
a tremendous impact on the history of rome
and we've done bios on all of them and each
time we mentioned another man who in turn had a
great influence on their own lives and careers
pompeii he was arguably the most successful
military leader that rome had ever known and
today we're giving him his due it's time for the
man himself to take center stage in a special
extended two-part biographic series as we look
at the life and the career of pompeii the great
pompei was born nias pompeus magnus on
september 29 106 bc in the region of
python he was part of a family that was in the
midst of a quick climb up rome social ladder
just a few decades earlier the name jen's pompeia
would have meant nothing to the average roman they
were after all plebeians meaning that they were
free romans but not part of the elite patrician
class basically they were just commoners but in
141 bc a man named quintus pompeos became the
first family member to receive a consulship this
opened the door for other pompeians to attain
important political officers as well as fill
up the family coffers consequently by the time
pompei was born his father neues pompeous strabo
was among the richest men in python that being
said it appears that strabo was not a popular man
quite the opposite in fact playtalk noted that
when strabo died seemingly after being struck by a
thunderbolt people took the body from the funeral
pyre and dragged it through the streets while
throwing stones and hurling insults at it so
yeah not exactly a man of the people which put
him in stark contrast with pompeii in fact the
same plutarch mentions that never in roman history
had there ever been a bigger gulf between father
and son in terms of how much the people hated
one and loved the other the historian simply
fawns over pompeii as if you are the president
of his fan club here's what he says no roman
ever enjoyed heartier goodwill on the part of his
countrymen or one which began sooner or reached a
greater height in his prosperity or remained
more constant in his adversity than pompey did
there were many reasons for the love bestowed on
pompeii his modest and temperate way of living his
training in the arts of war his persuasive speech
his trustworthy character and his tact in meeting
people so that no man asked a favor with less
offense or bestowed one with a better men for
in addition to his other graces he had the art
of giving without arrogance and of receiving
without loss of dignity that's just one paragraph
there is more but we don't have time for the whole
love fest today suffice to say that pompeii was
a popular dude with the people now we've probably
mentioned this before but it is worth repeating
barring extraordinary examples such as today's
subject the romans had a pretty standard sequence
for the men of the upper classes to advance their
careers it was called the cursus honorum and it
started with the office of crester and ideally
it ended with the position of console before that
though it was expected that the men would serve in
the military so that meant that that was pompeii's
first stop he joined his father's command around
90 bc and fought in the social war this was not
one of rome's more famous conflicts but it was
an important one nonetheless because it led to
the complete romanization of italy basically
back then rome was the dominant power in
italy but it didn't control all of it yet
it had multiple allies in the region known as
saki but they were unhappy that they weren't
granted the same rights as citizens of rome
so in 91 bc they went to war the fighting
went on for four years and even though rome
won the soggy ultimately got what they wanted
as they were granted roman citizenship in
order to avoid similar conflicts in the future
strabo obtained his biggest moment of glory at
the battle of ascalon in 89 bc and before this
he was celebrated on the streets of rome with a
triumph and was named consul for that year as far
as pompei was concerned it was a bit too early for
him to shine as a soldier however in 87 bc once
his father died and he inherited the family estate
that became a different matter entirely pompeii
didn't have to wait too long to put his burgeoning
military prowess to good use because in 84 bc
rome became embroiled in its fiercest power
struggle yet known as sulla's civil war
now we've already talked about solar here on
biographics so if you want the full picture
of that conflict you can give that video a quick
watch basically rome was in the grips of a civil
war between two factions one led by sulla and the
other by gaius marius and lucius cornelius sinner
pretty early on into the war it became evident
that this wasn't the kind of conflict where
other romans could just stick their heads in the
sand and wait for it to blow over everyone had
to choose a side or it would be chosen for them
for pompeii the decision was fairly easy since
he bore a grudge against sinner referring back
to godor plutarch again the historian said the
young pompei escaped an assassination attempt
engineered by sinner when campaigning with his
father this was after sinner supposedly bribed a
man named lucius torrentius to stab pompeii while
he was sleeping in his tent given that gas marius
died early during the civil war and sooner became
the leader of his faction it's no surprise that
pompeii decided to throw his lot in with sulla
but he almost didn't get the chance to do it
as he nearly lost everything at the outset of
the wall when the marius cinefaction took over
rome they began enacting proscriptions those
that were found guilty were declared outlaws they
had their properties confiscated and most were
also executed just for good measure at first they
did this solely to the supporters of sula but they
generously expanded their program to include
many other romans whose wealth they coveted and
pompeii soon counted himself among those wretched
souls accused of stealing some of the booty from
the battle of asculum if he would be found guilty
his property would be confiscated and he would be
lucky to escape with his life but that's not what
happened instead he managed to prove that a freed
man in his father's employ was the true booty
thief that plus his natural charms managed to
sway the magistrates who found him innocent he
even married the judge's daughter and to steer
the first of his five wives realistically pompey
probably escaped with his life and his wealth
intact because his enemies didn't perceive the
young and experienced soldier as much of a threat
even so pompey definitely knew not to attempt
to pay so he quickly left rome and retreated to
paison there he seemingly fell off the grid
for the next few years but what pompe was
really doing was quietly recruiting troops and
waiting for the right time to strike and that
time came in 83 bc when sulla and his army began
marching on rome this was the point of no return
for pompeii once he aligned himself with sula he
intertwined their fate either both men ended up
rich and powerful beyond their wildest dreams
or they both got their heads chopped off and
mounted on pikes both good options but let's just
say pompey probably preferred the first one and
it's not like he was the only one taking this
gamble another name you'll probably recognize
marcus crassus also allied himself with sulla
as did another influential roman general
named mattelus pires without a doubt pompeii was
the youngest and least experienced in that group
but he had two things going for him first he had
the money to equip and train all of the troops and
second he was just so damn likable and charismatic
you think that this might not matter so much
this was after all war and not a talent show
competition but the reality was that both sides
were in full-on recruitment mode and every man
pompei enticed to his side meant fewer soldiers
fighting for his enemy it is said that pompeii
started out with only one legion when he left
paison but had amassed three legions by the time
he actually entered battle and speaking of which
let's get to that fighting like guys marius
sinner had also died by this point and a guy named
cabo was running the show before joining with sula
pompei scored three quick and surprising victories
against three of cabo's generals wenzilla heard
of this he raced to meet this young upstart and
when the two finally met pompey hailed sulla as
imperator in return sula got off his horse took
off his helmet and returned the same greeting and
this was a massive show of respect on behalf of
the experienced veteran sulla who more or less
made it clear to everyone that the 23 year old
was now his protege and to be fair pompey paid off
this trust in spades after meeting with sulla he
left for gaul where he provided reinforcements but
metallus he wasn't present at the decisive battle
of the choline gate which won solar the civil
war but it was then tasked by sulla with chasing
down the remaining opposition so that they would
not be able to raise new armies and reignite the
conflict this included cabo himself who abandoned
rome once he knew the war was lost he intended to
retreat to africa to gather new troops but he only
made it as far as sicily before pompeii caught up
to him captured him and had him executed pompey
then crossed the mediterranean into africa and
was successful in crushing the last remnants of
the marius in a faction at the battle of utica in
81 bc once his task was complete it was time for
pompeii to go back to rome and enjoy his spoils
of war so you ever wondered where you come from
who are your relatives a few generations removed
are what they did where they lived well with
myheritage the sponsor of today's video prepare
to shine a light on your past and learn something
amazing but personally i'm not someone who knew a
ton about where they came from just vague
stories from parents and grandparents but
not a lot of really concrete stuff so having my
heritage has been amazing to add some details
to those rather vague stories an example
well as a kid my nan often talked about how
her father my great-grandfather was an
early pilot in the raf the royal air force
in world war one and you kind of never know
with stories like that well what exactly is
the hard truth what is embellished well thanks to
my heritage i dived into all of that and i found
out that my great-granddad was in the raf he was
a lieutenant and i found these handwritten records
of him doing this stuff and medals and all of
this and he was the part of these bombing runs
into europe which was pretty crazy even cooler my
heritage found a picture of him posing in uniform
as a young man it was all kind of grainy but
they have this cool tool which enhances photos
and at first i was like why is this zooming in
hearts please but uh technology has apparently
come some way because it took this great photo and
it made it amazing on screen now not even joking
you can also colorize photos animate them if you
want to the tools really are pretty incredible
my heritage has over 18 billion records so
it's not exactly a surprise that i found some
stuff about me and it is the number one family
history service in europe they make it super easy
to build a family tree going back many generations
i got back as far as the 1850s so far so click the
link below you'll get a 14 day free trial to enjoy
all the amazing features myheritage has to offer
if you decide to continue your subscription you'll
get a 50 discount and now back to today's video
the streets of rome were flooded with cheers and
exaltations as pompeii made his triumphant return
not to be outdone by the common rabble
sula greeted his protege with the name
pompeous magnus pope the great the title that he
would use from then on silver also arranged for
the young general to divorce his first wife
and marry his stepdaughter amelia who died
during a miscarriage less than a year later and
of course along with the respect and power pompe
was also granted untold wealth like marius and
sinner before him solar enacted prescriptions
on his political enemies and allowed his closest
allies to do pretty much whatever they wanted in
order to enrich themselves it didn't take long
for all of this success to go to pompeii's head
he was still in his mid-20s and already one
of the richest and most powerful men in rome
and he felt like showing off nowadays he'd
probably post pictures of himself in his
private jet on social media but pompeii wanted
the first century version of an insta brag
a triumph through the city streets sulla balked
at the idea nobody as young as pompeii had
ever celebrated such an honor according to roman
law only a consul or a pray till might receive a
triumph and pompeii who had scarcely grown a beard
as yet wasn't old enough to even become a senator
but hey silla initiated a civil war and declared
himself dictators so who was he to give lectures
on roman traditions despite many protestations
from other officials sulla relented and pompeo was
given his triumph but this little vanity project
it didn't exactly go according to plan instead of
having his chariot pulled by horses through the
streets pompeii wanted it drawn by four elephants
that he brought back from africa except he
didn't realize that the elephants would be
too wide to fit through the city gates so right at
the beginning of the triumph the procession had to
stop outside of rome and have the elephant swapped
with horses all while pompeii sat in his chariot
waving at everyone like an idiot and pretending
that nothing was wrong but despite occasional
missteps pompeii's reputation flourished if
there was one thing that could endear someone
to all the classes of rome it was military glory
and so far pompeii had a spotless record but his
meteoric rise rubbed some people the wrong way
including sulla who began resenting his young
disciple tensions between the two increased over
a man named marcus emelius lepidus schuller hated
him and called him the worst of men pompe for
whatever reason not only liked him but publicly
campaigned for lepidus to be appointed consul the
deterioration of the relationship between mentor
and protege became evident after sula's death
in 78 bc because he completely snubbed pompei
in his will even though he bequeathed gifts to his
other friends furthermore sula delivered a final
i told you so from beyond the grave because
that same year lepidus was named consul and
then tried to stage his own rebellion and
take over power by force he was joined by
sinner the younger the son of the man who fought
against sulla as well as marcus junius brutus
the father of caesar's future assassin in fact
lebanese also asked a young up-and-coming julius
caesar to join his uprising but he wisely decided
to stay out of this one probably civil wars just
weren't his thing anyway lepidus's main rival was
a man named catalyst the other console it's worth
reminding everyone that the roman republic always
had two consoles at the same time so that no man
could gain absolute power although it certainly
didn't stop them from trying but catalyst wasn't
exactly praised for his unparalleled military
genius so the senate was hoping that pompeii
might lend a hand as well unfortunately for
him he did despite his previously hardened
support of lepidus pompey did his mayor culpa and
rallied against him he was sent to mutina in gaul
which was lepidus neck of the woods to lay siege
on brutus that way assuming cattlers would also
be victorious labradors would be left with nowhere
to retreat and regroup pompe's siege was lengthy
but successful and upon capturing brutus he
quickly had him executed even though the latter
had surrendered this wasn't the first time that
pompey had one of his opponents killed under let's
just say iffy circumstances cabo had suffered the
same fate and his death earned pompe the anonymous
moniker of adlocentlus carnifex the teenage
butcher meanwhile catalyst also achieved his goal
and defeated lepidus at the battle of the milvian
bridge although his victory wasn't decisive enough
to completely negate lepidus as a threat once
again pompeii the closer was sent in to obtain
a more permanent result which he got sort of he
defeated lebanese in battle but the latter was
still able to escape and flee to sardinia where
he fell ill and died so well mission accomplished
already pompey had amassed an impressive military
resume many other commanders would have used
all of that stockpiled glory to parlay it into a
safe cushy position as a senator a governor maybe
even a consul in fact that's exactly what catalyst
was hoping pompe would do given the last decade
or so where rome saw conflict after conflict
right outside at city gates any military leader
with command of a loyal army was cause for concern
after all who knows what ideas pompeii might get
that's why catalyst told him to pay his soldiers
disband his army and return to rome where he could
be properly feasted for his victory as it turns
out catalyst was right to be concerned because
pompeii did not want to disband his army it
appears that glory in battle tasted much sweeter
to him than even the most sumptuous roman banquet
but at the same time he wasn't so gung-ho that he
was willing to make an enemy of the senate so he
searched for a compromise by seeking out another
conflict where his services might be needed and he
found it in the iberian peninsula or hispania as
the romans called it that region was under the
hegemony of a general called quintus satorius
a former ally of sinner and marius satorius
packed up his bags and retreated to espana
when his side lost the civil war there he found
allies in some of the local liberian tribes and
made himself the de facto ruler of the peninsula
ever since then rome had been trying to retake
control of the region but had failed to do so
granted it didn't allocate a lot of resources to
the problem since lepidus was more of a pressing
issue but satorius also proved himself quite adept
at doing a lot with a little since he was usually
outmanned now gunned he often resorted to guerilla
warfare to disable his enemies and prevent a
pitched battle from happening this strategy
worked for years in fact when pompei got in on the
action satorius was already successfully foiling
pompeii's former military ally metellus pires
the reality of pompei's actions was again iffy
since he disobeyed nord from catalyst and kept
coming up with excuses to not disband his army
he was relying on his supporters in the senate
particularly a senator named lucius philippus
as well as others who realized that they needed
pompei regardless of their feelings towards him
philippus even suggested that pompeii be given the
authority of a pro-consul referring to a military
or administrative leader who was given powers
outside of a regular term traditionally only
men who had previously served as consoles could
be made pro-consuls pompeii meanwhile had never
held the position of crystal the first stop on the
cursor sonorum however as we saw with his military
triumph its first military triumph we should
specify pompeii was an extraordinary man one
for whom the standard rules simply did not apply
pompey arrived in hispania in the spring of 76 bc
this would be his home for the next five years as
sartorius would prove to be his biggest challenge
yet in fact pompeii started off his part in
the satorian war as it was known with a very
inauspicious and rare event a defeat in battle
at the siege of laurel and it wasn't due to being
outnumbered or some natural disaster either on
that day sartorius was simply the better general
he allowed his opponent to think he had the upper
hand when in fact he was falling for an ambush the
young cocky pompei realized too late that his men
were marching into a trap and by that point there
was nothing he could do but watch up to 10 000 of
his soldiers get slaughtered by sartorius forces
the shocking outcome left pompe reeling some of
the shine came off the golden boy who up until
that point seemed like he could do no wrong but he
made a comeback following year sartorius mistake
was thinking that pompeii was a beaten man he
left him to his underlings while sartorius himself
went to deal with metalis but the pompeii of
old returned at the battle of valentia in 75
bc and he not only defeated tutorials as generals
but also inflicted massive losses on their armies
thus compensating for his shameful performance
at leron the next time he fought stories in
battle was at the battle of sucrow and then the
battle of sagundam that same year both ended in
stalemates afterwards satorius decided to retreat
into the mountains regroup his forces and resume
his guerrilla tactics by attacking supply lines
and scouting parties at the same time pompeii's
side was starting to run thin on troops and
resources so he sent word to rome to ask
for money supplies and reinforcements since both
camps were in rebuilding mode the next few years
were pretty quiet with only the occasional
skirmish breaking up the monotony this was
fine for pompeii but sartorius was dealing
with in-house problems low morale defections
conflicts between romans and iberians all spurred
on by one of his generals marcus papurna who
coveted the top spot for himself ultimately it was
treachery and hubris that ended the satorian war
papuana and his co-conspirators assassinated
satorius at a feast in 73 bc a mistake that would
shortly bring on their own demise for whatever
reason paper assumed that things would magically
get better with him in charge but it was quite
the opposite since papuana was destined to be
robin to satorious as batman he just didn't have
the charisma the experience or the skill to be an
effective leader many of his troops abandoned him
either defecting to the other side or simply going
home when metal has heard that satorius was dead
he was confident that pompeii could handle the
remnants of his army so he returned to rome the
latter indeed proved up to the task using a simple
decoy tactic to lure paper nia's troops into the
open and then crushing them in an ambush papernia
and most of his officers were captured and
summarily executed as per pompei's regular
modus operandi he still had to spend some time
taking care of stragglers but pompeii had won
the satorian war he was getting ready to return
to rome where he would undoubtedly enjoy another
triumph when he received words that an escaped
gladiator was causing chaos throughout italy not
one to pass up a good fight pompeii had found his
next opponent spartacus but we'll talk about that
when we pick up the story in part two the
wrath of pompeii so subscribe and stay tuned
you